men look for reasons why babe wouldn't
sleep with a girl whereas women look for
reasons why they would sleep with a man
so the default position for man is you
know I would sleep with her unless
there's some extraordinary reason why I
shouldn't
whereas for women it's I'm definitely
not gonna sleep with him unless there's
some particular reason why I should Rob
Henderson in the building how are you
man good Chris how are you yeah great
great to have you on here welcome to the
UK cheering lockdown as well by the way
yeah yeah it's great to be here you know
in the middle of this pandemic so what
are we going to be talking about today
yeah I thought we talked about some
evolutionary psychology and social
psychology and what's going on with
modern dating modern in the sense of you
know the 2020 but also in the sense of
what's gonna happen with this
coronavirus and how that might affect
the dating scene - I can't wait I love
it so what do we stop yeah I mean I
suppose we can start with some some
basic evolutionary psychology so just
right off the top here I mean you know a
lot of people have questions about why
do we like what we like how flexible are
our preferences you know why why does it
seem like men seem to be attracted to
younger women why do women seem to be
attracted to exceptionally wealthy men
and of course there could be some
cultural components but a lot of it from
evolutionary psychology focuses on sort
of more innate or more cross-cultural
preferences and they basically are
looking at you know what what is sort of
evolutionarily advantageous for human
beings to pass on their their genes and
so evolution operates at the level of
the gene and so sometimes we do things
that are advantageous for our genes but
they actually hurt ourselves what like
something like for example for men will
sit with men risk taking so on average
women tend to
be attracted to men who take risks in
intelligent ways but things like say
motorcycle riding or bungee jumping or
certain kinds of sports I mean these are
you know typically more attractive and
they're also extremely risky and so
things like this can can attract
partners you know if you know partners
but they can also put your life in
danger but that's one of the interesting
things about evolutionary psychology I
mean what are the the principles is that
you know if you have a trait that is
reproductively advantageous but harmful
to yourself that trait will still tend
to proliferate whereas if you have a
trait that is advantageous for survival
but turns off the opposite sex then that
trait will tend to disappear from the
population so say you have some kind of
trait that promotes longevity but I
don't know it makes you look unusual in
some way well or it just turns the
opposite sex off and it doesn't matter
that it's keeping you alive if you can't
find a partner that gene is going to
wear those jeans are going to disappear
so something else that's important to
know about evolutionary psychology and
men and women that women take on a much
greater burden with child-rearing
than men do so if you think about what
does a man have to invest to have a
child well really not much more than a
few minutes of activity and you find
it's maybe being very generous to a
couple well yeah I'm trying to be nice
we've all loved it we've all not about
night all right
you know that's true that's true and
there are some so yeah exactly so so
some men they invest abuse minutes maybe
two seconds in some cases whereas for
women they have to invest I mean if a
woman happens to get pregnant have a
child I mean that is you know nine
months of pregnancy followed by you know
years of having to take care of a child
and so on and so in the ancestral
environment women took on a much greater
burden and so women have evolved to be
particularly choosy about who they
partner with they tend to be more
scrutinizing they evaluate men to see
whether man is is a you know sort of
worthy partner whereas men tend to be
slightly less you know scrutinizing and
yeah a little bit more relaxed in in
terms of who they're willing to to have
sex with when it comes to long-term
relationships men do have some rigid
standards about a Google partner with
but even though today we have birth
control we have all of these
reproductive technologies and so on our
brains and our bodies are still sort of
stuck in this Stone Age you know humans
there's some debate about this but
humans haven't really changed much in
the last hundred thousand years or so
and so some strategies that we act today
reproductively are more beneficial for a
different environment for the ancestral
environment yeah I'd know a good example
of this I think is men fighting and the
increased chance of men fighting one as
a group we seen this oh oh yeah I
haven't seen that specifically but that
makes sense so if there's men tend to
fight it's a display of dominance
there's a an embedded winner and loser
behavior mechanism as well that the
loser cowers it means that I am lower
that the winner kind of is up and tall
stand up straight with your shoulders
back and apparently I can't remember
where I ready I'm just swimming in
evolutionary psychology at the moment so
it's like David buss or Robert ride or
Rob Henderson and yeah that's when
there's a group of people observing a
man's likelihood of fighting of getting
to a physical altercation goes up and
that would make sense in an evolutionary
standpoint right if you are in a tribe
of showing us 50 people in it and
everybody knows everything that's
happened and there's people watching and
you back down from a fight they might
think in future I can push Rob around
that guy's a [ __ ] whereas if you stand
up for yourself even if you potentially
lose but if you stand up for yourself
people might think yet Rob's worthy of
respect yeah yeah yeah that that seems
to yeah that seems to align
with with some evolutionary a psychology
principles and yeah when there is a
crowd it would make sense that men are
sort of more willing to engage in like
sort of physical altercation I've also
seen you know if you look at data I
think Martin Wilson and Margo daily I'm
getting the names right Wilson and Daly
in any case are the last names they
looked at young male homicides and the
causes of young male homicides in the
United States and what they found is
that most homicides started over what
they called trivial altercations
essentially sort of minor insults you
know sort of dissing one another or
insulting one another and these are the
most the most common reason for a male
homicide is because of these trivial
altercations what they discovered and so
interesting I just read a blog post
about this on Psychology Today by
douglas kendrick and he said that if
you're a young man one of the things you
can do to promote your own survival and
longevity is to be polite to other young
men simply because you know
disrespecting another young man is
actually very dangerous based on based
on some of these findings on on what
causes men to kill one another
trivial altercations man so thank you
don't knock someone's drink over or cut
in line at the supermarket oh well
there's not enough people to supermarket
at the moment anyway to allow that is
that you got to keep two meter distance
so okay so men and women have different
risks associated with having sex and
until recently we were unable to have
any reliable form of protection despite
how accurate and well time do you think
you would for all game is contraceptive
strategy yeah so what else do we need to
know yeah I mean something else that
might be interesting are you know so
I've read a lot about about men in
particular you know why we are driven to
do these things that but that we do
and something like like weightlifting or
playing sports things like this well one
reason why for example men want a weight
lift is to build big muscles and the
research does show on research on
attraction that women are more attracted
to men with big muscles muscular men are
they report having more sexual partners
relative to less muscular men part of
this is because you know building
muscles is costly right it's a sort of
fitness indicator not in this not
Fitness in the sense of like you know
sporty or athletic but but Fitness in
terms of reproductive fitness Darwinian
Fitness if you can build muscles it
indicates a lot of things about you it
indicates that you're able to obtain you
know calories the resources necessary to
build those muscles it indicates
conscientiousness which is a personality
trait someone who can who regularly goes
to the gym that person is diligent and
hard-working they have goals and stick
to them and then of course you know they
confer protective advantages to you know
people are less likely to mess with a
with a muscular guy relative to a
smaller guy yeah
and so yeah you see some of this in the
research
yeah muscular men report more sexual
sexual partners yeah I just want to kind
of dig into that for a second here the
fact that women find those traits
attractive and a man has those traits
suggests that if she was to mate with
him that her children have those traits
which means that they are more likely to
reproduce because other women will find
that to be attractive yeah yeah so this
is some call this the sexy Sun
hypothesis yeah yeah so this is I first
learned about this I think in Matt
Ridley's book the Red Queen this the
sexy Sun hypothesis is basically this
idea that women are attracted to men who
are attractive to other women and the
reason is because if they have sons with
this man that their sons will also be
attractive to lots of women and thereby
you know
pass on those genes but yeah I mean the
basic idea describing is that yeah when
women wants men who have certain
qualities because you know those
qualities will tend to pass down to
their offspring but I think it's also
important to make clear that these
aren't you know these aren't calculated
or sort of you know deliberate you know
strategies that were enacting a lot of
this is going on sort of under the hood
we're not even aware of why we like what
we like or what we do what we do we just
know that it makes us feel good you know
so you know what when a woman likes a
muscular man it's not because you know
all of these operations are going on
well if my kids will be muscular and if
there's a woman out there who's gone
through her gone through that discourse
that we've just heard in her mind I want
to meet her and to talk to her because
she'd be isolating but yeah it's you
totally correct and that was the point I
really wanted to try and get out of you
can you explain how genes and what they
do to promote genetic fitness and
emotions and feelings and the more
conscious sided brain how those two
things interlinked I think
is it Robert right that says genes are
the Preferences and emotions that our
executors something like that yeah yeah
I mean genes are basically selected for
and basically through evolutionary
pressures shaped certain behaviors and
of course like there are other factors
involve cultural factors social factors
and so on but you know a lot of our
behaviors are strategies enacted through
through our genes and it's not like
we're consciously aware of it we're just
sort of going through these motions in
the same way that say you know when
you're when you're eating sugar you're
not going through this calculated
process of you know well I'm eating the
sugar because it's giving me caloric
energy which I can expend later and so
on the sugar just makes us feel good and
our genes give us this little reward you
know our biology gives us this little
being like okay you're eating sugar it
makes you feel good because that's
advantageous but things don't make you
feel good for no reason right like
everything that makes you feel good is
something that at least in the ancestral
environment you know paid off in an
evolutionary sense so when you're when
you see a beautiful woman or you see a
particularly you know athletic man or
whatever it happens to be you feel a
little bit good and you feel some
positive response to that and none of
this is deliberate or calculated it's
it's just sort of you know built right
in to us and you know it's it's yeah
well it's not it's not anything that
that we're really thinking about
necessarily yeah for sure I think this
for me is precisely why I've found
evolutionary psychology to be so
interesting it is looking it's it's even
looking under the hood it's taken the
engine apart and it's looking inside of
the engine it's looking at why do we
like the things that we like why are our
preferences the way they are and then
when you take that you take the fact
that we have these unwritten rules about
the way that we operate and then you
apply them to an environment in which
they were absolutely not designed to
operate which is where we are now I
guess was it the last 10,000 years
probably I guess it'd be maybe two five
thousand to ten thousand years or so
would be beginning but especially now
yeah you totally right
a perfect example I love the idea of
guys going to the gym displaying the
fact that they're able to get surplus
calories as surplus calories are
something which would have been a rarity
you know fifty fifty thousand years ago
when all of our problems were problems
have scarcity not problems of abundance
like now right and a guy who's able to
be big oh my god he must be an
unbelievable hunter he was really very
diligent like you say must be very
conscientious but people are now able to
game that system you know right like you
choosing to eat the protein shake and go
to the gym and lift some weights and
stuff that's gaming the system right
yeah yeah and on that point about you
know going to the gym and building big
muscles so they don't want to touch on
earlier about this you know a lot of
these sort of secondary male
characteristics there's a there's a
paper called Beauty and the Beast by
this I think is an evolutionary
psychologist David putz and he basically
found evidence for these secondary male
sexual characteristics evolving not
necessarily only to attract women but
also to signal dominance towards other
men to basically intimidate potential
sexual partner sexual rivals and
basically he found is that you know if
you show women pictures of you know
muscular men for example and ask how
attractive they are you know women do
have a small preference for a muscular
man relative to less muscular men but if
you ask men how intimidating a muscular
man looks relative to a non muscular man
men are actually like the effect size
for intimidation men are much more
intimidated by that other
characteristics like beards so there's a
wide debate you know online and
everywhere else you know do women like
beards or not and I say you got a little
stubble going on there right they say I
can't decide I'm trying to play both
comes at the same time row but that's it
yeah well fortunately you know you can
grow it out you can shave it you know
there's weave options but for beers the
evidence is totally mixed about whether
women actually
them or not whereas for men if you ask
them how intimidating is this man with
the beard versus without men are very
likely to say he's more intimidating
with the beard almost no man would say
clean-shaven men is more intimidating
than a man with a beard looks so
mistrusted did you have a look at men
with checkered shirts I think it was you
who tweeted the study and then I tagged
a couple of my buddies in it am i right
in saying that the most robust
characteristic of physical trait for a
man to have is muscle size it was more
effective than low voice that beard and
then height is that okay so I saw a
study that was a big analysis and there
was varying small degrees little bits
here and there with certain women
certain age ranges of what they liked in
men across the most robust strategy for
making a man more attractive to women
across age ranges was just put put some
muscle on so yeah if you listen in if
you listening you struggling you've had
a little bit of a dry spell and you can
clean up I don't know whether to grow
beer to go to the gym go to the gym
first good maybe grow the beard while
you're at the gym yes some some
interaction there um so yeah and and so
there was an interesting study related
to this where they basically so a group
of researchers took a group of men and
had them speak to a camera you know just
a few minutes recording these short
videos of these men and then they showed
these videos to different participants
so they showed these videos to first to
a group of women and then they had these
women watching these videos and asked
them how sexually attractive do you find
this man and I think it rated him on a
scale of one to seven and then they
showed those same videos to a group of
men and asked these men how likely is it
that this man in this video would win a
physical fight with another man again
like scale one to seven right and then
they tracked the men in those videos
eighteen months later and basically
asked them how many sexual partners they
had over those last 18 months
they found that the number of sexual
partners they had was associated with
how formidable they looked how tough
they looked to men that was that there
was a link there but there was no link
between how many partners they had and
how attractive they were to women so it
actually looks like talking look is more
predictive of how many partners you'll
have than how sort of sexy you look like
yes what you're saying
Rob is the men a better picking out men
are gonna get laid than women are in in
a way I you know I don't know if you put
it quite that way yeah okay yeah you
know looking at how tough a guy looks
yeah yes so we have different
preferences for men and women we have
this ancestral environment which is
where our genes were created they have
these feelings and these emotions that
execute what we should be doing our
behaviors and our preferences and things
like that some of them were either not
conscious at all partly conscious or
kind of completely conscious you know
when you see a woman or a man who piques
your interest in you god that's like
she's hot he's hot whatever so what what
do we move onto next what's next yeah
yeah I mean we can look at for example I
mean we could we could even go back to
and this could this could maybe connect
to some some of the more modern dating
kind of stuff but you know again so men
have have far smaller investments in
insects compared to women again you know
the sort of few minutes few seconds kind
of thing so it's it's advantageous
actually evolutionarily for men to seek
more variety they tend to be more
interested in novelty I just listened to
his podcast I think it was Justin Lee
Miller who's a sex researcher and he
reported that basically when women have
sexual fantasies it tends to be the same
person throughout the duration of the
fantasy
whereas for men men tend to switch you
know who they're fantasizing about you
know minute to minute as there's any any
man or woman who's listening nose is
completely impractical and holy would be
an operational nightmare
in real life you be yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah of course but but yeah and the
fantasy men will sort of go through
these different scenes different people
and so on whereas women tend to stick
with the same person and then you see
this sort of in real life - well the
thing is so if you look at number of
sexual partners straight men straight
women tend to report about four to six
sexual partners is the median number
that men and women report in the u.s. at
least lesbian women are about the same
four to six sexual partners but if you
look at gay men the numbers are
something like 16 to 20 sexual partners
the thing is like you know they're
basically I think this is is a more sort
of representative look at male sexuality
in a way I think straight men would
prefer to have 20 partners versus four
partners but you know they have
different challenges right they you know
they have to basically convince women to
like them and women are are choosier in
comparison right and so yeah I mean and
this is something else also that's
interesting you know women women are
choosier in a sense but the psychologist
Steve Stewart Williams it's got a pretty
big Twitter account he he has called you
know he sort of described women's sexual
strategies as selectively promiscuous
and what that means is that women will
you know it basically if a man has
exceptionally high status if you're a
rock star or you know an actor or
something like that you can tend to it
you can basically get a lot of female
sexual partners many women will sort of
reduce their standards for emotional
commitment or for trust or cooperation
or all of these kindness these kinds of
things
if a man has you know this
extraordinarily high status so women can
be in some cases sort of this
selectively promiscuous as you stir
Williams puts it but in there in the in
general in their daily lives they tend
to be you know quite careful yeah so why
want to kind of touch on here is that we
have this
evolutionary landscape which has an
asymmetry no matter what you think men
and women aren't the same at least in
this particular domain I do not want to
get into the deeper discussion of other
men and women are not the same in terms
of their investment in how children are
born and what that means is that women
have to be the gatekeepers and men have
to be the sexual protagonists what I
think is interesting is that you see
these roles play out in cultural memes
that become caricatures right so you
know every man as a woman ever been
called a sleaze sleeves you know like
you are a creep like okay there's no
woman who's ever so much the sexual
protagonist that a man would call her a
sleaze but that's a common put-down for
men right you know or a fuck-boy or what
you know we pick your vernacular what
have you want to say sure you have that
but you like hang in a second that is a
modern-day interpretation of an ancient
system at work right then that the fact
that oh well he should text first
perfect example like why should a man
text first
well probably because you have as a
woman you have more to lose by a sexual
encounter which means that you need to
make him jump through more hoops to get
to have that sex because the react for
you traditionally over the last 100,000
years has been higher therefore you're
the gatekeeper he's the protagonist but
yeah that is a perfect example of how
the modern world of dating the modern
interactions that every man and woman
that's listening will no reflect that
right right yeah yeah you can see this
yeah even even in our more enlightened
age you know the other day for example I
was talking to a woman and she told me
that she had a crush this with this you
know this guy at her work and I asked
her you know why don't you ask him out
then and she said oh I would never ask a
guy out and I said but you really liked
him right a number of my old friends
they would say exactly the same thing
she said no matter how much I like a guy
I would never ask him out
and can you imagine a guy saying this
like one of your guy friends you know he
likes a some woman and you say ask her
out and he says no matter how much I
like a woman I would never ask her out
does that make sense that doesn't
compute right and so yeah we see these
you know as you're saying this sort of
protagonist this sort of gatekeeper it's
a perfect experiment there to the man
into the women that are listening to the
woman how many times have you gone up to
a guy and said hey I think you're really
hot are you single or whatever now you
may have gone up to a guy and said my
friend who sat on that table thinks that
you're reading singer but that doesn't
count so don't try and slip it past me
and then on the flip reverse of that for
men how many times has a girl come up to
you and said and said the same thing
like is it I can count you know I've
worked a lot of night in my life and I'm
man eight I can remember probably most
of the times that that's happened is of
a very exceptionally unique makeup of a
girl who is prepared to go and do that
right well why why is that the ice is it
could can such a skew in people's
behavior simply be socio-cultural right
yeah yeah and I'm not aware of any any
culture or society in which it is the
norm for women to ask men out on dates
or sort of take the initiative in these
courtship rituals yeah yeah that's
absolutely right and I think it's it
could be even more important you know
it's just this may be because sort of
transition into into yeah this sort of
modern dating it could be more important
for women to take this initiatives
especially educated women because among
the educated population within the US
and I think within most Western
countries now there are more educated
women than there are educated men and so
if you're an educated woman looking for
a partner who's also educated things are
actually looking quite tough for them
it's about dating monkey at the moment
yeah yeah it really is
you know coronavirus aside you know even
before all of this I think yeah things
were looking
actually quite grim if you look at the
data for for especially educated single
women so there's this great book just a
couple years old from John Berger called
Daytona Mix and he basically ran a bunch
of analyses looking at basically you
know how many single men and how many
single women are there how many educated
women worse educated women and so on and
what he basically found is that among
people with bachelor's degrees or above
who are in their you know 20s and their
30s sort of young adults young singles
there are 33% more women than men so
there are four women who are
college-educated compared to every three
men and so basically the market is
actually looking quite you know quite
unappealing or sort of not me not an
appealing but you know it's not looking
good for women whereas for men it's
actually the opposite so if you're an
educated man there's actually a surplus
of potential partners for you
in part because if you're an educated
man you can date educated women of which
there are more you know educated women
than men but you can also date less
educated women right
whereas educated women and tend to be
more reluctant to date men who are less
educated for some of the reasons that we
mentioned before women want men who have
certain qualities now there are some
cases where women will date men who are
less educated than them but what the
research shows is that in those cases
their partners tend to earn more than
them and in fact women who date men with
less education are twice as likely to be
married to a man who has higher income
than themselves so you know if you
basically if you're an uneducated man
all hope is not lost for you if you want
an educated woman but you just have to
earn a lot more money you gotta get you
guys I've got a hustle mannequin so yeah
exactly so again here's another cultural
meme and I I can I can feel the the
triggering I can feel it happening even
in myself right like I I don't like
hearing the fact that women have high
pergamus dating preferences that they
date what is referred to as open across
right they will they it's the same
perfect example of this is
there are any tall girls who are
listening you don't tend to want to date
a guy that shorter than you if you take
that as a characteristic across most
important elements of dating you most
women on the whole don't want to date a
man who earns less than them or who is
less educated than them and if you are
less educated you need to compensate by
earning significantly more as the data
would suggest but you know it's very
easy to turn that into a caricature and
what's a caricature of that the gold
digger no that's the modern that's the
fuck-boy tinder generation whatsapp
world speak you know what that it's it's
the girl who is purely interested in
resource acquisition and it's again it's
challenging to it's challenging to try
and get this across without it sounding
like a value judgment that either
encourages or discourages says it's
either good or bad
this isn't I'm gonna try and create some
form of disclaimer for Rob as well here
this is either of us saying that this is
good or bad this is the way that people
should or should not behave but right I
would challenge anybody that's listening
to say that this isn't the way that
people behave we have some pretty robust
data and everybody knows everybody knows
the guy who is prepared to sleep with
women who are of varying standards but I
don't know many women that are prepared
to sleep with men who are of varying
standards does that make sense yeah yeah
yeah that's absolutely right yeah and
yeah it's important that you know the
studies that I'm describing and you know
some of these you know generalizations
these observations you know they're
they're descriptions right they're not
they're not prescriptions so these are
sort of you know describing what people
do but it's not saying this is what
people should do you know some people
sort of make this you know what's called
the naturalistic fallacy which is
basically that just because something
exists in nature that means that's the
way it should be
but clearly this isn't the case I mean
you know coronavirus exists right that
arose you know that you know someone
need a bat or something and now there's
this pandemic should that be the way it
is not as a darkness on a nighttime yeah
yeah yeah so so yeah there are some
maybe less savory aspects of human
nature but doesn't mean you shouldn't
act it but we are describing it I think
describing it and talking about it and
bringing some of these out into the
light can help us you know inhibit it or
redirect it to something that would
align more with our moral commitments
and you know try to try to make people
happier so what a perfect example of
this too
before we delve fully into the world of
tinder a perfect example of this is the
modern the modern set up of monogamy
right yeah what you're I'm gonna ask you
to put your money where your mouth is
now having read a fair bit of
evolutionary psychology what's your
feelings on what would have been a
typical ancestral set up for
relationships yeah so I mean basically
what I've read for you know what goes on
hunter-gatherer societies they were
largely monogamous for the most part for
multiple reasons one reason is it was
essentially impossible to stockpile
resources in a hunter-gatherer foraging
society so a man could not accumulate
vast amounts of material wealth simply
because if you're in a small band or a
tribe and you're constantly moving you
know going where the food is where the
water is you can't hoard like lots of
material resources and carry it around
with you
that's one reason and then another is
that simply you know men had to rely on
one another and trust one another in war
and in hunting and you know men aren't
going to go you know fight for you know
their someone in their in their tribe
who has all of the women right like why
would they do that
and so basically men had to essentially
I mean this sounds you know maybe
doesn't sound so good but basically like
men had to create a system where the
sort of access to sexual partners or
whatever
roughly equal in order for the tribe to
survive now this doesn't mean that in
hunter-gatherer societies you know
infidelity didn't didn't exist or you
know mate poaching which is you know
luring someone else out of a
relationship like there's there's
research on modern-day hunter-gatherer
societies and there is infidelity there
is you know cheating there's you know
divorce exists in a way we're basically
like you know people will switch
partners later on and leave their
current partner so there's a there's all
the things you know all these things
that are sort of recognizably parts of
human nature but you know polygamy and
its variations didn't appear to exist
until the at the rise of Agriculture
once people were able to sit in one
place and and stockpile resources the
invention of money the ability to have
you know the to command large armies and
so on those things didn't come until
after the advent of Agriculture but in
small bands they were mostly monogamous
is my understanding but you know the
question often the question is you know
are we naturally monogamous are we
naturally promiscuous what are we and
the answer is were kind of both there is
no you know Universal template for human
beings it looks like in terms of
stability
monogamy is the best both you know maybe
modern society and also in in forging
societies but you know people still do
have urges and people want to you know
have have more than one partner divorces
widespread and so yeah we sort of want
to what does it have our cake and eat it
too yeah yeah which is very you know
that's very human yeah the show okay so
we're moving into the movement in the
modern world moving into tinder and and
and modern dating and stuff like that
what you've been thinking about to do
with that recently yeah yeah well one
thing that's been on my mind lately and
I talked about this in a recent
newsletter is what is coronavirus going
to do with you know with casual sex
which you know tinder these other apps
are associated more with with sort of
casual sex although people do meet the
partners on them and you know you can't
like all the bars are shut down right
like you can't go out you can't go to
restaurants like you can't meet anyone
anywhere and so that's you know one
obstacle if you want to meet someone new
and another is we don't know has this
virus man like are you like excited to
go meet someone new if you don't know
like who has this virus who doesn't like
he's eager to like have a new sex
partner who might have coded 19 so yeah
this is something that my my impression
is that there will be less casual sex at
least throughout the course of this
epidemic and I think people will sort of
recommend to whatever relationships they
happen to be in for now after this is
all over I'll be curious to see how it
goes
you know I've heard some stories about
you know couples who live together are
starting to feel you know a little bit
irritated at their partner because
they've been cooped up inside for so
long with this sort of social distancing
stuff but yeah yeah tenders are
interesting you know speaking of you
know education and and so on this there
was a study I think it was this year it
was late last year on tinder I want to
say was in the Netherlands where they
basically took male profiles on tinder
took the same exact man same profile and
all they did was change his education so
in one profile the man had a bachelor's
degree and in another profile same man
he had a master's degree and found that
the man with the master's degree got
about twice as many likes compared to
the man with the bachelor's degree so
yeah you know you mentioned earlier to
your listeners here you know hit the gym
but maybe also you know hit the books if
you want to get home there's only so
many hours in the day that's right
well prioritize one or the other but
yeah so this is pretty interesting even
on tinder you see these these sorts of
you know these sorts of mating
strategies emerge in terms of status
education
and all these kinds of signals and you
know relatedly you know given that the
economy seems to be tanking right now
this could be bad news for some men and
may be good news for others but
basically when the research shows this
this rise in in sexy selfies right so
this is this research basically that was
it was done on on sexy selfies and what
they found was that basically so they
had a question you know why are women
taking sexy photos of themselves in this
way how can i define sexy photo I'm not
exactly sure but you know sort of
provocative maybe you know not wearing
much something like that because Leila
photos or well fellow collabs and stuff
like that okay all right sort of Beach
photos this kind of thing and so the
researchers asked well are women doing
this because like aren't the societies
women doing this in more misogynistic
maybe societies that are more likely to
objectify women or view them as sex you
know justjust for because of their
sexuality or something like that or
could it be something else and so they
basically like collected you know data
from all of these different countries
different regions within countries and
they found that you know the misogyny of
a country had nothing to do with how
many sexy selfies women were posting but
what sexy selfies were associated with
was economic inequality within developed
countries so for example within the US
in regions like New York City or Miami
San Francisco places where there's a
bigger gap in in income between men
you're going to find a proliferation of
more female sexy selfies and the
researchers posit that the reason for
this could be that you know if there is
a small number of men who have a lot of
economic resources women are basically
competing it's sort of advertising
themselves to these men they have to
open that game basically they're upping
their game in in regions where yeah
basically there's a lot of hats and
rather a few halves and a lot of
have-nots and yeah I mean there's
there's also interesting research from
the 2008 economic recession on
purchasing habits of women and what they
found was that shortly after the 2008
economic recession sales of cosmetics
increased and again you know the
researchers there posited that you know
in an economic downturn where you know
women are again sort of upping their
game trying to find the the relatively
fewer men who are economically
successful in those situations and I
feel like we're sort of like just you
know talking about women and it's you
know like you mentioned gold diggers
earlier I want to I want to again you
know sort of just click you write this
disclaimer here that you know women
aren't gold diggers or anything but but
that they are enacting a strategy that
paid off for their ancestors rights who
I don't care about your feelings
Robin unfortunately in the guy from date
anomic snow that firsthand well why
don't we why don't we flip it on its
head why don't we start talking about
the gender sex gap between men and women
so I know that I think it's the bottom
80% of men
on tinder are competing for the bottom
20% of women oh yeah yeah that's right
that was a that was a fascinating
finding yeah where they basically found
yeah exactly what you what you're
describing here that you know men who
are not you know exceptionally
good-looking or or have certain status
markers that they're having a much
harder time on tinder just to put this
into perspective if I recall these
numbers correctly men on average swipe
60 percent of the female profiles they
see they like them was it swipe swipe
right yeah you know they like those
profiles pretend you don't know Robert I
know I mean let me pull up my app real
quick and then whereas women on the
other hand I think it was 4% they swipe
right on 4% of the male profiles they
see an unbelievably low number I mean
just purely from a time investment
standpoint you get through a hundred
people to get full four right swipes and
if you have a particularly bad afternoon
it's not a ridiculous stat to think you
might not strike with swipe right on
anyone unbelievable it's almost like the
experiences are completely different
right whereas I mean like I once this
this wasn't a psychologist I just in a
casual conversation I once heard someone
describe this the sort of difference
between men and women in terms of you
know how they evaluate the opposite sex
wars something like men look for reasons
why they wouldn't sleep with a girl
whereas women look for reasons why they
would sleep with a man so the default
position for man is you know I would
sleep with her unless there's some
extraordinary reason why I shouldn't
whereas for women it's I'm definitely
not gonna sleep with him unless there's
some particular reason why I should and
this is sort of you know we're seeing
this in on tinder right with with the
frequency of right swipes so yeah so
basically there's a large group of men
who are collecting large numbers of
likes I have a friend and you probably
know guys like this who are racking up
huge huge numbers on these dating apps
yeah I have a friend who has you know
something like 20,000 plus matches on
tinder
I think he closed it down he ended up
getting a relationship and he settled
down but for a while he didn't I'm
surprised he didn't break the [ __ ]
service yeah hosed it down because
tinder came in and they said sorry we
just can't give this account anymore
storage space with you 20,000 likes yeah
just shut it all down it was actually
opposite I don't know how this happened
but he was a tinder identified him as
like some kind of valuable user and like
give him all of these perks and benefits
and like lifted his limitations on how
many whites is it like Amazon Prime or
something I feel if you've ever
if you've ever actually spent more than
a thousand pounds in a year on
booking.com you get to become a genius
and Bukovina booking.com genius is
fantastic you get 10% off you get early
check-in so I wonder if he got like
early check-in and yeah it's actually
the equivalent of that no I haven't I've
never gotten those privileges sometimes
Amazon sends me complimentary protein
bars nice because I order so many of
them but I've never never never anything
like free Amazon Prime but um but yeah
so you have guys like like my friend
here who has all of these likes and then
you have other guys and I think this is
probably more typical of the male
experience on dating apps where you know
they go through you know dozens or
hundreds of profiles and get maybe a
handful of matches with women and so
yeah this is this is sort of the typical
male experience where you know the
competition isn't as tough and one thing
I'm concerned about now with with the
economic downturn is that could get
tougher as well more guys losing their
jobs yeah and full of guys maybe you
know guys guys who've been work from
home you know podcasters and so on who
you know have stay at home gigs you know
things might might turn out pretty good
for for them but for other guys hoping
Rob here's hoping my so [ __ ] you [ __ ]
that's right
I've been praying for a pandemic to
happen so that how you dating a dating
situation can improve not man it's um
again this isn't the tough pill for men
to swallow and and you know when we talk
about a world which I absolutely haven't
delved into but in cells MIG tau which
men going their own way red pill black
pill movement Rollo Tomassi is gonna
come on at some point when I can finally
get a hold of him you know all of this
all of this kind of like men going the
wrong way thing I think is is in
response to the challenges that men are
seeing in the dating market it's
increasingly hard for men to find women
the stats don't lie I can't remember how
big the sample size was for tinder but
it was I remember that they analyzed a
lot the difference between how many men
that's 8020 which is so funny that the
Pareto distribution as well that 80/20
distribution between the bottom 80% of
men competing for the bottom 20% of
women which conversely means that the
top 80% of men of women are competing
for the top 20% of men like you're such
that top 20% of men have such an unfair
advantage yeah and I got I got a comment
an unbelievably long comment that was
very well very well written a lot I
didn't understand most of the language
and it's someone who had crawled out
from these reddit sub threads about make
Tao and in cells and stuff like that and
had said about he was making a comment
on a girl that I had on recently who
created a website like only fans long
story short he said one of the things he
accused me of playing the game because
I'm 32 and still single he said that if
I was if I was being charitable /
respectful generally for men as a whole
I wouldn't continue staying single until
32 the implication is that I'm playing
the game that I'm tying up the options
of a number of different girls
throughout throughout their twenties
throughout their twenties throughout
their twenties which is restricting men
from I mean first off I was very
flattered but yeah as like to say it's
secondly the
the fact it was so well written man like
it was a decent comment was he had line
breaks and he'd managed to make [ __ ]
bowled on YouTube I didn't even know you
could do that so I'm like this is this
guy is this a [ __ ] it's small thisis you
should submit it at Cambridge and um he
went through I replied I rotated this
tiny little reply and then he went again
and he there was a little bit of sort of
vitriol in it but what made me really
sit back was that it was very well
balanced and worded he obviously
understood what he's talking about and I
was like there is an entire body of
knowledge here trying to figure out why
men aren't getting laid yeah yeah yeah I
think that I mean that that that
definitely sort of is at least to me a
very charitable probably one of the more
charitable uh you know interpretations
I've seen back on da way of telling it
yeah right but but yeah I mean there are
a lot of guys out there who are
struggling I know guys like this who
aren't doing so well in terms of dating
in terms of jobs you know they're not
where they want to be and yeah they're
struggling and you know I don't I don't
think guys like you or anything like
tying tying women up or anything like
that you know in terms of keeping them
out of out of the dating pool but I do
think there are some challenges right
now simply because the modern world is
you know there's a mismatch between our
sort of innate desires and the way that
the modern world is set up such that you
know there aren't as many men in college
and women tend to prefer educated men
but you know men are going to college
and you know people are wondering why
that is there aren't as many you know
men who are earning in terms of the
millennial generation I believe that
women are earning as much and it's in
case even more than millennial men at
least in the UK I read this so you got
to educate it rich yeah women
yes men are better educated and richer
which again is you know there's nothing
wrong with that but if they're looking
for male partners they're going to look
for men who are
so better educated and richer and
preferably even more educated and richer
than themselves so this is now becoming
the tall friend right there becoming the
tall friend who can only date basketball
players and a you know like pro sports
guys because and and the the converse of
that is really really bad for both men
and women which is mmm
the alternative if women tend to date
open across or they their preference is
to date opened across to richer and or
better educated men and there are a few
of those men around there's two choices
left which is both genders get to remain
single for the rest of their life or
women get into relationships with men
that they're fundamentally unattracted
to which is also not ideal all right
I mean well there's also the other
option would be women can part when we
can essentially share a man right so so
some people have speculated that this is
what's basically going on in these
gender imbalanced communities like like
universities and colleges where there's
a surplus of women relative to men men
are much more likely to play the field
so to speak you know they're more
reluctant to settle down more interested
in casual sex and so on and in colleges
where there are more men than women
there's actually more relationships more
emotional commitment and more of a
dating culture and some people find this
surprising but it's really not because
in these colleges with more men their
men are basically competing to to you
know get a get a girlfriend and women on
average tend to prefer you know
courtship commitment relationships and
so on and in environments where there
are more women than men women basically
have to compete for the small pool of
men and what do men like well men on
average tend to like you know more
casual situations you know more
short-term relationships one-night
stands you know
things that are more casual and so women
are more likely to do those things to
try to get men to like them so they've
got to play each of this game right when
right men are the surplus rather than
the scarcity they have to play women's
game and when women are the surplus
rather than the scarcity they have to
play men's game right yeah and we're
seeing we're seeing a kind of inversion
I mean I think in the past when men had
more education than women maybe was
maybe maybe monogamy was easier in some
way simply because you know if men or
yeah if women prefer dating men who are
educated and have higher earnings and so
on relative to themselves then yeah I
think maybe it was easier back then in
some ways and today when things are sort
of flipped and they're there were
personnel where women have more
education and so on than men becomes
harder and so some people have suggested
that polygamy or some variation of that
will arise there's a lot of a single
very high sex but a lot to overcome
there and I think the the whole we
haven't really delved into it too much
that is a whole nother two-hour episode
I think if we try and really get into
how does monogamy help with resource
distribution but from men to women etc
etc yeah I wonder I wonder what an
increase in sexual liberation for women
in education for women in you know we're
talking now we're using terms speaking
about the fact that women are
potentially too educated to date men or
at least to dead men that they are
attracted to that they're potentially
almost shooting themselves in the foot
by their earnings and by their level of
education because they're reducing their
own dating pool down and I wonder as we
go through potentially more gender pay
changing and I don't know what the
immediate future has in store I mean the
immediate future has absolutely [ __ ] all
in store because everyone's locked in
the house but the after that once we
once the world rebuilt mmm yeah yeah
yeah you know in in the shorter term I'm
more pessimistic I think like basically
no one has the answer right now and
we're gonna sort of fumble and muddle
our way through trying to figure out you
know what to do you know in some ways
and you know I've written about this you
know a lot of men are simply just
dropping out like you know you mentioned
the the big toe guys McTell guys you
know a lot of the guys now more and more
it seems are just not interested in
relationships at all and they're sort of
retreating into you know video games or
porn or these other you know sort of
distractions and I wonder if as
technology improves
you know once like you know there's a
virtual reality where a man can put on a
set of goggles or something and lose
himself in some you know fictional porn
world whether you know some small
percentage of guys will just be okay
with that so may increasingly bigger
percentage if does potentially yeah and
in that case yeah in the real world
basically there will be even if you were
men for women you know as men continue
to drop out and then you know there
could be some some sort of equilibrium
reached where yeah maybe put like some
mix of polygamy and and reapered
technology and so on well you know we'll
have a new norm arise I was there all in
this
I was talking to Douglas Murray guy the
madness of crowds I had him on the
podcast again he's unbelievable guy I
don't know whether you've seen either
but he's got jacked
yes Robert jacked out of nowhere no I
just saw him a couple weeks ago and he
had you knows blazer on and his shirt
and everything I had no idea that was
underneath Hollywood anyone anyone
that's listening that remembers my
episode with Douglas I mean he'd had a
couple of wines so he's fairly loose it
anyway but he he just looked like normal
dude normal guy but he has been pounding
the gym go and his gun his Twitter
search Douglas Murray go in his Twitter
have a look
they got his jacked out of his mind um
well anyway so I was talking to him and
he in his book monitor crowds he's got
this chapter about women and he talks
about he's
sniffing less diplomatic than mean you
have been this evening but he's he's
talking to one of his friends and his
friend said he was saying how's your
young son who's 17 or 18 or something
like that I'm is he is he dating anyone
and his friend replied and said oh no
he's not interested in girls and
obviously Douglas is a gay man
immediately oh my god he's not [ __ ]
gay is he like just having seen like the
potential future that this this fella
had ahead for him oh right and he said
oh no no no he's he's not gay he's just
kind of thinks that women are a little
bit difficult to get his head around so
he's kind of just exited that situation
I can tree what you said he was doing
like working lot on his career and maybe
pull it may be doing music or playing
video games or something but you can
imagine that you know if you are the
bottom 80% of men who are
disenfranchised from the dating market
who essentially can only get yourself
into a relationship where your partner
Loki is unattractive to you even if they
don't know it and you feel like you're
the worst of the bad bunch I mean sorry
for red peeling you this evening about
it but I'm single as folks I can say
what I want but you know if that's what
happens like it's the potential for a
whole [ __ ] disenfranchised male
militia of single guys walking around
and I think that you know as much as
they're very very well-spoken and have
some incredibly sophisticated arguments
there is a significant portion of the
McDowell red pill in sell reddit
movement for whom this is probably the
easiest explanation mmm yeah yeah yeah I
think I think so and there are there are
more and more guys I've noticed who
either yeah I mean to me that mindset of
this the seventeen-year-old kid is
unimaginable you know when I was 17 with
my friends were 17 like you know girls
were all we could pause like that's all
we could think about it was like sports
and girls and that's about it and yeah
I'm seeing more young guys just sort of
like either either say they're not worth
it or say that they can't figure
or they didn't really know and just
general confusion and you know one of
the things I think is important you know
having conversations like this because
when guys go online you know there are
some very toxic parts of the internet
right where guys go like you know you
were talking about caricatures earlier
they you know sort of take you know
principles in evolutionary psychology or
in research and then they exaggerate
them or they you know sort of turn them
into the worst possible version of what
the finding was in order to you know who
swage their own feeling about why they
can't get a girlfriend or something like
that and yeah I mean I have some
sympathy for these guys too but I mean I
think that there's a lot of this sort of
red pill nikto stuff is is really just
sort of you know they want girlfriends
right and and this is what's what it
would in less time like your your missus
would not let you spend five hours a day
on reddit so the presumption is that if
you're on reddit five hours a day you
haven't got a bird yeah so but the
alternative is unless girls are going
gay and I haven't got I don't know the
stats about that but unless girls are
going gay they're not dating either if
men aren't dating women women aren't
dating men that's not necessarily true
so women can date a man who is dating
multiple women right so you know I think
this is probably what this YouTube
commenter guy you mentioned earlier was
- you know when he said your your
cereals hogging up these women so you as
a 32 year olds you know good-looking guy
you probably have you know six or seven
girls on the side no okay sorry yeah
yeah and so and so I think this is this
this could be going on here you know I
have I have friends who speculated this
I don't actually know of any research
but I have friends who speculate you
know a lot of guys they know have you
know four five six girls through tinder
that they're sort of shuffling through
there was that big piece of Vanity Fair
a couple of years ago where they
interviewed all these guys and they're
like you know I you know whatever I
racked up 40 grit this year or whatever
it is and
and so yeah I think a lot of women are
you know sort of dating or hooking up
with guys who are seeing multiple women
on the side and then there's a lot of
men out there who really aren't seeing
anyone and that gets us through the
casual stage of relationships but it
doesn't ask for long-term partners I
said oh I see we just yeah yeah so what
do you think I think yeah yeah yeah I'm
I'm not I'm not sure what's what's going
to happen there currently I mean it
looks like I mean relationships are
still forming but at a lower rate right
marriage rates are declining divorce
rates are increasing divorce well my
understands divorce rates have mostly
stabilized but but marriage rates have
declined and people getting married at
older and older ages to this is what
hope yet mum yeah yeah for both of us so
yeah long-term relationships you know
they'll probably survive I mean we've
we've gone I mean as humans right we're
very very adaptable flexible so yeah
that's one of the one of the most
interesting things from reading
evolutionary psychology that just how
adaptable humans are just how they're
able to take you know we the fact that
we're able to step into our conscious
process you know even the fact like this
whole conversation here why do we think
this why do we have this preference why
do women like this while men like that
why's that this disparity between the
certain the other the fact that we're
consciously able to step in and look at
our own programming means that we're
able to transcend it the problem is that
you can't get rid of the preferences
like evolution is a slow process
especially when you have a an
environment like the Monde world which
is changing so fast evolution is
pointless at the moment anyway
what are you evolving to adapt to but by
the time you have your kids the
situation that they've got the genes to
be adapted to has gone yeah it's partly
being being unbelievable at writing on a
typewriter because now there's a laptop
it's pointless at being able to be
fantastic flying a plane because now
there's surface-to-air missiles and it's
the engineers that are take you know you
know I mean yeah yeah yeah and and yeah
one of the things that's sort of tragic
and perhaps one reason I think why you
know people are so afraid of getting old
there was this piece in The Wall Street
Journal recently how old people now
don't want to be called senior citizens
you know sort of baby boomers they'd
rather be called you know something else
they're trying to find a different label
for themselves because they're terrified
of being associated with that label
senior citizen they know you what a
senior citizen was when they would not a
senior citizen exactly and people are
terrified of aging and the thing is like
in in more traditional societies
foraging societies a lot of status was
conferred on on old people right well
one reason was because if you could make
it to that age you know you're you're
robust you know in that environment if
you can live to 60 or 70 and then
another reason is because you've
accumulated all this knowledge that that
will help the tribe survive
whereas today it's the exact opposite
it's the 20 year olds who know sort of
the most about you know societal trends
and you know sort of what people are
thinking and feeling and where the
direction of things are going and older
people are sort of out of the loop and I
think there's there's something sad
about that you know that things that
flip this much where we've created a
society somehow where young people have
more status than old people in in some
ways ya know I couldn't agree more
especially when one of the things that
you are able to accrue as you get older
is wisdom
and now with the advent of free
information free global information at
the touch of a button there are no
longer gatekeepers to that wisdom there
is more information on the internet than
your granddad will ever know yeah with
that in mind it becomes a lot less about
life experience and a much more about
kind of very brute force learning and
skill acquisition abilities you know if
you can learn something fast if you're
able to do rote recall like very
effectively or whatever you pick pick
your skill about learning right if your
aims
do that you're so much quicker ahead if
you can live in two in two years what
takes someone else 20 it doesn't matter
how old they are literally doesn't
matter how old it you know yeah it's um
man it's it's fascinating times at the
moment I I feel like we've only just
scratched the surface as well Rob I
would love to get you back on if you'd
be so kind I mean we've got you know I
know I know that you've got fuck-all
else to do at the moment because you
quarantined man love of God just podcast
me again connection yeah I know
look there will be so many questions and
comments and feedback if you've got
anything that you've been interested in
throughout this conversation why should
they go on Twitter to hustle you yeah
you can just follow me at Rob Kay
Henderson so ro Bek Henderson sweet yeah
I'd love to hear everybody's feedback
about this I want to know if you're a
girl who's the protagonist in dating or
if you've got a sister that does it or
if you're a guy who's finding it easy on
tinder or hard on tinder or whatever you
know this is an very much an emerging
field and if you can help to shine a
light for me and Rob then that will make
us better educate it as well I also have
to give a massive shout out Rob to your
mailing list I think it's fantastic I'm
subscribed to I think it's at five
mailing list total and yours is one of
them so the link to that will be in the
show notes below as well link to Rob's
Twitter dudes I hope that you enjoy oh
let's finish up sex toy sales we can get
into sex toy sales
tell me about sex ourselves yes so
basically since since the spread of this
pandemic the coronavirus thing sex toy
sales have increased yeah multiple
countries they increased I think 71% in
Italy yeah the increase in Canada these
times do not give a [ __ ] do they yeah
yeah I think yeah people sort of know
especially single people they know that
they're gonna be locked down for a while
and you're not going to be able to jump
on tinder and
and scratch that edge so it's time to to
order some you know that's a cent
increase yeah so so they're probably
yeah besides like zoom you know I think
sex toy companies are also making a lot
of money right now you know that's the
mom no one talking about that only
everyone's talking about the stock
market crashing but no one's talking
about the price of silicon that's wrong
the price of silicon is going through
the roof latex catsuit yeah there's a
little of everything yeah look Rob I'm
gonna house with you I'm gonna bring you
back on man this is absolutely amazing
links to everything we've spoken about
mailing lists Rob's Twitter all the rest
of it you know what to do like share and
subscribe if you're new here hit the
subscribe button you get an episode
every Monday and every Thursday with the
most interesting humans on the planet
like the wonderful Rob but for now
thanks man
alright thanks Chris
[Music]
you